south side from 808 mafia uh was was
here the other day
and he was uh he was off of two perks
during the interview and then explaining
perks like having sex on perks to me and
how it's kind of like
it's like its own thing like perk sex is
better than regular sex for the for the
girl i guess
i don't know what it is
have you have you ever done the honey
pack or the blue rhino with the gas
station no i'm scared of those what
about the blue right over but i heard he
packed the dial for sure the honeypot is
serious back in i think if i do some
[ __ ] like that because i'd be having a
whole bunch of crazy girl drama so
they're going to be even more sprung if
you [ __ ] take a vitamin oh [ __ ] like
that yeah that's oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no it's
not it's not anymore
not anymore by the way go to
bluetooth.com right now cause i was
[ __ ] 16. use the promo code blue like
first month free at the same time if you
have a 16 they can take eat peels and
drink a hell of liquor trying to charge
that battery oh yeah ain't nothing like
that
you've never been so drunk that you have
like whiskey drinks
in your life i don't be drunk for real
like in your life you've never gotten
before your will i'm lame did you say
you never [ __ ] one two and three hurt
[ __ ] you
did you say that you've never [ __ ] the
[ __ ] off of pure will before hell no
not not only only [ __ ] like
i [ __ ] one [ __ ] i like off for a long
time off pure wheel you forgive me other
than that i was waking up
yeah [ __ ] since i was 16 when i [ __ ]
around and did it by accident i was off
hella drugs [ __ ] and drunk and i [ __ ]
the [ __ ] for like three hours i'm like
yeah i know that wasn't just me that's
not normal you feel me something they
got there since then yeah we
something else and something else
sometimes like i'll go down i'll go to
mexico and get the generic viagra oh
[ __ ] you know some freaky ass old names
i ain't going live
my moana is a drink it's a it's like a
wine drink that they they say it's uh
they call it american power at his house
it's like wood in it yeah in it oh my
god i got it on my house
it's wood in it so it's it keeps it
dominican it's a dominican aphrodisiac
it keep refilling drink
that [ __ ] keep refilling yourself or
something bro it's wood in that so if
you go to if you ever go to like a
dominican
resort
yeah it's like it's like a it's like if
you were to go to mexico and they gave
you corona or tequila it's like they're
in the dr mama wanna is like a
it's like a it's like going to [ __ ]
detroit going to a coney place you know
what i'm saying it's very [ __ ]
so it's it's a wine
exactly
wood and [ __ ] and then they pour it and
it's it's it refill itself or some [ __ ]
and that shouldn't get you [ __ ] up but
it was definitely
[Music]
do that no your dick's gonna be hard
you're gonna be drunk no like drunk that
ain't my type of thing most people can't
hide like i don't really like drinking
have you ever been so high you can't
[ __ ] off a weed no hell no i don't know
i'm just asking i ain't never not been
able
[Music]
have you ever like
liked a [ __ ]
but got to the point where you're about
to [ __ ] her for the first time
and that [ __ ] stinks
but it's stank yeah yeah i'm kicking
that [ __ ] out you you got to kick her
out right yeah you've never i ain't bi
so you've never been like
man we already here no i didn't i didn't
have this though never pulled one of
these doggy styles
i didn't i just had this though i didn't
a [ __ ] [ __ ] was stanking and then i
got in her [ __ ]
out of nowhere she got a period i don't
know but that [ __ ] had to go no cat
that [ __ ] was